Yahoo reports on a story that's gotten a
lot of attention made a lot of headlines
from the from the college football World
a prominent football coach has been
suspended soon to be fired most likely
after claims of sexual harassment and
the media has done their usual routine
of just basically assuming the guy is
guilty the school's assuming the same
and there are some people on the other
side that are defending the coach and
saying no he's certainly innocent
um and I sort of think that everyone is
wrong so it's one of those cases but
here's the story
Michigan State head football coach Mel
Tucker has been suspended after reports
he sexually harassed anti-rape activist
Brenda Tracy multiple media reports uh
reported late Saturday night the Tucker
allegedly harassed Tracy as she was
working with his team Tracy a rape
Survivor who works with college football
teams and other organizations regarding
sexual assault education filed a
complaint with Michigan State regarding
Tucker's alleged actions and he's been
the subject of a Title IX investigation
at the school Tucker 51 is 19 and 14 in
his time in Michigan States as Michigan
State's head coach though 11 of those
wins came in one season he was hired by
the Spartans ahead of the 2020 season
after one year's Colorado's head coach
after a two and five debut season
Michigan Michigan went 11-2 in 2021 and
won the Peach Bowl
the rapid Improvement earn Tucker a
10-year contract extension with 95
million dollars guaranteed
that money however is guaranteed only if
Tucker is fired without cause and is at
risk if the school finds that Tucker
quote engaged in any conduct which
constitutes moral turpitude or which in
the University's reasonable judgment
would tend to bring public disrespect
contempt or ridicule
Okay so
reading about the contract there because
there's some important contexts
potentially Michigan State
um locked in with a 95 million dollar
contract
which by the way is already insane that
universities have this kind of money to
spend on football coaches nothing new
nothing this is not news I realize but
it's worth reflecting on just a moment
95 million dollars
on a football coach
okay but there's a if there's a student
debt crisis it's on the taxpayers to fix
we're the ones who have to fix it
so the schools themselves have hundreds
of millions lying around for football
coaches
but we have to pay off the loans of the
college kids that those same schools
scammed
um
which is why you know I've always been
very much opposed to student debt relief
you know because that really means uh
redistribution of wealth where we're
taking from people who didn't take out
the loans you know Working Class People
didn't have loans and uh we're paying
off the loans of college graduates it's
kind of like a an upper class welfare
system so I've always been opposed to
that
however the the one form of student debt
relief student debt forgiveness that I
personally could entertain is where
you're taking the money from the schools
you're forcing the schools
uh to pay off the loans now that's
something we could talk about
the schools are the ones running this
scam and they're also the ones who have
hundreds of millions of dollars again
laying around
anyway
um so they locked in for this contract
based on one good season his other
seasons have not been that good so now
they could potentially Salvage most of
that money if they fire him with cause
for committing sexual harassment the
other point that we have to mention here
is that uh this is a this is a black
head coach
which you know that that does become
relevant
because
um there's very much an incentive for
these schools to get big contracts to
blackhead coaches so that they can show
up you know he got this he got this
contract in 2020 probably not a
coincidence
um but then also if they want to fire
somebody like that then that's all the
more reason why they need to have uh
they need to have cause they need to
have a scandal
so we start to understand what their
motive motivations the school
motivations might be
to take this claim seriously reading on
uh Tracy says that Tucker made sexual
comments about her and masturbated
during a phone call between the two uh
in April 2022 according to USA Today
Tucker acknowledged his conduct during
the phone call to Michigan State
investigators and said in a letter to
investigators the two were having
consensual quote phone sex
according to the USA Today report Tucker
who is married pursued Tracy
romantically after she started working
with the team she reportedly told
investigators she rebuffed Tucker's
advances before he called her for over a
half hour on April 26th
now some more important context that's
not mentioned here it's been shown
through phone records that Tracy and
Tucker had I think
27 phone calls that all averaged about
30 minutes
before this
um before the alleged sexual harassment
and the and all that
27 phone calls
for 30 minutes
I have not talked on the phone with
anyone for 30 minutes since I was in
high school maybe
so now imagine
it's like 30 minutes on the phone is a
long time that is a long time especially
especially these days that's that might
as well be 30 days on the phone I mean
that is that is a that is a marathon
phone call and now imagine 27 calls with
a person for 30 minutes
the significance of that is it would
seem to very very much suggest that they
were in some kind of romantic
relationship
okay and I certainly cannot imagine a
situation where a woman where it would
be appropriate for a woman to have 27 30
minute phone calls often late at night
with a married man
who she knew who she knew was married of
course Vladimir Putin called the U.S
dollars drop in dominance objective and
irreversible as Brazil Russia China
India and South Africa formerly agreed
to use local currencies and trade
instead of the U.S dollar as demand for
the dollar weakens the buying power of
the dollar also weakens that's why Birch
gold is busier than ever investors and
Savers are looking to harness the power
of physical gold held in a tax sheltered
IRA and you can too you could protect
your IRA or 401K by Diversified with
gold from Birch gold as the U.S dollar
continues to receive pressure from
foreign countries digital currency and
central banks arm yourself with
information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
too text Walsh to 989-898 and they'll
send you a free info kit on gold with an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five star reviews I trust
Birch gold to help you diversify into
gold if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it'll be nice to have
some gold to depend on again text Walsh
to 989898
also by the way Tucker says that two
months after the phone sex call she sent
him a happy Father's Day text message
okay
continuing uh now we're going to read
what she told investigators about what
happened
in her interview Tracy became extremely
tearful to the point of sobbing
describing this portion of the party's
encounter
um a report from Michigan State obtained
by USA Today said Tracy could hear
Tucker masturbating including quote
every stroke she could hear the noise of
some kind of lubrication being used
Tracy said it was so loud and gross she
could hear Tucker moaning and groaning
Tracy kind of froze in the moment at
first
Tracy thought to herself oh my God this
is happening and I can't stop it it's
going to happen whether I like it or not
Tracy was trying to figure out what to
do it didn't occur to Tracy that she
could hang up
Tracy kept thinking over and over that
she has to say something and that she
couldn't let this happen again referring
to her prior experience of being a
victim Survivor of sexual assault all
right
so
I don't know what happened I don't know
if if this guy is guilty or not of what
he's being accused of
here's what I think I do know uh that
there are no good guys in this case
there's really no one to root for right
you've got Michigan State giving this
insane contract to this guy then using
this claim to get out of it
you've got Tucker who at best at best
is a married man with children
having phone sex with some other woman
um and on top of that on top of the fact
that he's betraying his family which you
know is obviously the most important
point
he's doing this after getting a 95
million dollar contract
you just got paid a 95 million dollars
you're gonna put all that on the line
to have phone sex with some random woman
so just utterly treacherous and Reckless
and stupid Behavior by Tucker again at
best
and then you've got Tracy who at best at
chose to stay on the phone
for apparently 36 minutes while a guy
masturbates
rather than just hanging up the damned
phone
it didn't occur to her that she could
hang up what would it be it didn't occur
to you you forgot that there's a hang up
function on the phone you didn't
remember that
oh I can hang these things up I had no
idea Oh you mean I can oh I can take the
phone down from my ear and hang it up I
didn't I forgot that I could do that
so we're supposed to imagine her on the
phone like listening to this
and going I don't know what to do how do
I stop this how do I stop hearing this
thing that's coming out of this phone
that's right against my ear
um like is this the first time you've
ever used a phone in your life that you
did you don't know how these things work
so if Tucker had had uh had a
non-consensual phone sex
which you know sexual harassment if that
happened then he's a disgusting creep
um
at a minimum
if it was consensual he's still a creep
given that he's married
but there has to also be like a modicum
of personal responsibility that factors
into this
um for the person on the other end of
the phone where you like
you know it's not victim again again
assuming that that the claim is true
that he did this without permission or
without you know it was not reciprocal
it's not victim blaming to just say okay
like just
you have agency as a person at exercise
a little bit of personal agency it
doesn't take much it's not like they're
in the same room or something and she
can claim that she felt threatened by
his presence he's thousands of miles
away you're on the phone
but of course the bigger question is
whether the claim of the lack of consent
is even true and um you know some of
these additional facts really call that
into question
you know the the Happy Father's Day text
two months later if that's the case like
you're claiming you're traumatized by
this and then you text him happy
Father's Day after it that that's hard
to believe
um but but who knows I have no idea I
don't know Mel Tucker I don't know the
woman uh one could be a liar they both
could be Liars I have absolutely no idea
no idea all I can do is evaluate the
facts that are not in dispute
and those facts are that Mel Tucker is a
married man
who had phone sex whether reciprocal or
not with a woman who stayed on the phone
with him for 36 minutes a woman who was
on the phone with him often late at
night for half an hour at a time 27
times despite knowing that he's a
married man so it's just like one of
those things where nobody is doing the
right thing here and um
there just isn't any good guy at all
um and it does and by the way if if Mel
talker is innocent of the sexual
harassment claim
um
it
this is just another good reason to be
faithful to your wife
okay not that you deserve to have a
false accusation if it is false you know
no one deserves false accusations
but
um it is more difficult for me to have
sympathy for someone when you're putting
yourself in a situation like this
you're a married man going after this
other woman on the phone like you're
putting yourself if it's a false
accusation you're putting yourself in
that position despite your 95 million
dollar contract you've got a family to
lose you got a hundred million dollars
to lose and you still do that you're
you're a freaking
which is why I've seen I have seen some
people like I said uh some uh
uh mostly the media has just been
assuming the guy's guilty because that's
what you do in the metoo era I have seen
a few people going the other way some
some a few commentators said oh this
man's innocent he's being railroaded
he's
it's very hard to feel sorry for him
either one way or another I mean
honestly thanks for checking out this
video if you liked listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts